gentlemen ladies what if Superman had  decided to fly down rip off the roof of  the White House  grab the president right out of the Oval  Office who would have stopped him I want  to build a team of some very bad people  who I think can do some good  y'all Joker's must be crazy  what  this is the deal you disobey me you die  try to skate you die I'm gonna boyfriend  you irritate or vex me I'm known to be  quite vexing I'm just forewarning you  you'd uh they get caught we throw them  under the bus  what a ride let's play come on get  something better  I love this guy  not good don't forget for the bad guys  are you sweet-talking me all of that  chit chats gonna get charged ride  but you will do you will see songul yeah  one who sings dog yes I want to see stop  I was just trying to get you there  no our feelings all right we good  what you having beer whiskey what am i  12  how are you hot stuff water that's a  good idea